[Music]
this
is disney on ice
but as you can see there's much more to
the show
than skating one two
three and four three turn five six
crossover 70.
we got to meet some of the show's
principal performers
like nelson sanchez limit who plays the
role of woody
maria starr who plays elastigirl
and nathan miller and sophia adams who
star as aladdin
and princess jasmine
[Music]
we went behind the scenes i feel like
i'm a gymnast not gonna lie
to find out how these athletic
performers push themselves to limits
they didn't even know were possible
honestly six weeks ago i don't think
that i could do these
and now i could do them and talk to you
this is what it takes to perform in
disney on ice
we caught up with the cast and crew of
disney on ice presents
road trip adventures the brand's newest
show
just days before the company set out on
a two-year
67 city tour of north america
take a break
the show is created here at feld
entertainment studios in ellington
florida about 40 miles south of tampa
inside the 580 000 square foot facility
the cast and crew have spent roughly a
year putting the show together
rehearsing and training
six days a week for eight hours a day in
a full-size rink complete with lights
props
and high-end led screens we're in our
final rehearsals before
our first preview show and we're just
tying up loose ends and making last
minute changes
on the day of our visit friends and
family of felled entertainment employees
filled the arena to witness a special
preview performance of road trip
adventures
along with familiar faces like mickey
minnie
donald and goofy the new show features
segments from recent disney movies
like aladdin toy story 4
and mary poppins returns we partner with
the disney company to understand what's
in their content pipeline
what's new and different what's coming
out and from there
we pick out the moments that we feel
like are going to resonate the most with
audiences
[Music]
you use these skates for a long time or
i
never have them more than 11 months it's
like always
10 or 11 months all right so triple
little light fantastic
the number overall is looking really
great but there's three sections i
really want to clean up today
five six seven eight one two
three four five six seven eight
one and two road trip adventures cast
features
53 performers that's better feld
entertainment wouldn't share
details about their salaries but did say
that they are provided with health care
most of the skaters here have grown up
skating from
young children through competitions and
we really do
recruit and go out and really search the
talent
through competitions as they're coming
up through the different levels one
two three and four good so nelson just
make sure that your
heel together lean back lean forward
i was born in the american republic so
no winter no snow
no big rinks never even thought about
figure skating until i was 10 when i
moved
to canada i didn't really like the
competitive side of skating i was more
performing and letting the audience
enjoy the performance
so when i got too competitive i kind of
took a step back and i
looked at disney xeon ice so i was like
i have to do that that's my turn now
and here i am today i skated
competitively
and did that until i graduated high
school and then
i just applied for disney and i sent in
a skating resume and like video in my
skating and i got offered a job and i
was here a month later
and i've been on the road this will be
my 10th year i've actually been skating
for about 25 years now when i was a kid
i lived in oklahoma city and disneyland
always came through at the state fair
that was like a big highlight for me as
a child
and i always as a kid wanted to skate
alongside goofy and i mean here i am now
eight years and i still get to do it was
meeting goofy everything you hoped it
would be oh it was everything i hoped it
would be it was so much fun
i was just a competitive skater for the
u.s i've been training for
my whole life i've been to nationals
i've done the whole whole thing but i
really wanted to travel i really wanted
to
earn a living off of what i do as a
career i've been with the company for
about five years
i've traveled around the world almost on
every tour possible
but what is also extremely great about
this particular show is i actually get
to fly
while the show is called disney on ice
some performers spend a bulk of their
time
in the air
[Music]
in addition to skating the show features
complex
aerial choreography
[Music]
do the arab best death spiral release
and then we'll stop here
this requires collaboration between the
performers and crew members in charge of
operating the cables connected to their
harnesses
a lot of the people that we have have
never really flown before or done any
aerial work because they're
naturally skaters so where they've
started and where they are
now has grown so much so we are able to
do more the more that they are
comfortable with and can do
so we actually have to have a close
relationship with our operator when
we're learning this process because
you know there's only so much i can do
like i can't even come up to you yet
you know i'm kind of on a leash and so
you have to get together with an
operator to give you more slack less
luck
and tension and help me spin and fly so
instead of just working with a partner
you're also working with another partner
along with aerial work the show's cast
must develop
other skills that go beyond skating
this is called a roll up and it uses a
lot of abs
and upper body strength it really works
your back and all these muscles that we
never really use
as figure skaters but we have to use it
now
[Music]
nelson's upper body strength is put to
the test during the mary
poppins segment of the show
[Music]
being able to hold on for grip for so
long up there all my weights in my hands
for the first time ever you know we're
used to being on skates on our own body
it's all upper body now the mary poppins
segment
also combines feats of upper body
strength with aerial work
which occurs when the lamp posts
suddenly take flight
we always have communication it's the
most important part if something goes
wrong we have a few little
waves thumbs down means down you know
seat like this also means now like an
emergency exit
in case something goes wrong at first we
started low but the higher we started
going
it's definitely a little scary
not every role in disney on ice requires
quite the same level of athletic ability
but each part contributes to the overall
experience
especially figure skaters it's a very
solitary sport we don't grow up
um always working with a like a large
group together
getting them to see the bigger picture
know that it's not yourself out on the
ice by yourself
you're a part of a huge unit that's
performing in front of thousands of
people
so it's kind of getting the mindset of
your everyday figure skater into the
mindset of a professional athlete
they've grown a really close bond and
they've become really good friends they
support each other it's a really good
group of people
that we have here when i go out there
and see the audience react so well to us
and all these families come together and
share such a beautiful moment it gives
me so much joy
makes me miss my family but they're
proud of me
i know they're proud of me